Speaker 1: Let's get caught up on a few other
things going on. Republican Congressman Jim Jordan
from Ohio suddenly remembers another phone call
with then-President Donald Trump while the Trump
riots were going on on January six. Now, you might
remember that last month, Jim Jordan said he had a
phone call with Trump on January 6th. He couldn't
remember what they talked about. He couldn't
remember whether it was before the riots, during
the riots or after the riots. That's really weird.
We now have a new declaration from Jim Jordan, who
says to Politico, Look, I definitely spoke to the
president that day. I don't recall. I know it was
more than once. I just don't recall the time. So
now he is admitting to at least two phone calls
on the day of the Trump riots. And it's starting
to smell. It's starting to stink like a guy who's
just trying to get his story straight for possible
future testimony. Now, there's another funny
detail here as well. Jim Jordan was asked about
Matt Gates and whether Matt Gates was on that
phone call, was it a so-called three way phone
call? And Jim Jordan says he'd have to think about
it. That's a quote. I have to think about it,
saying that was a hectic, frenetic day and he had
many different conversations. That's also really
weird. You don't remember whether it was just
you talking to Trump or whether Matt Gates was
also on the phone. That's a really strange
thing. All of this is adding up to Jim Jordan
is an obvious liar. I'll remind you of a couple of
the clips. He's been asked this a couple of times.
These are almost like instant classic type clips.
Here is what where Brett Bayo was asking him about
the phone calls and his he just doesn't make any
sense. And you can tell Brett Baer is visibly
confused by what's going on. Remember this man?
Speaker 2: He's obviously going to go down a
number of different roads
about who knew what when,
who was talking to coordinators of the protests.
Did you talk to the former president that day?
Speaker 3: I've talked to the former
president umpteen times. Thousands. I mean,
I may not I mean, on January, countless,
countless times I talked to the president.
I never talk about what we talk about.
Speaker 1: So here is Jim Jordan first.
Just trying to avoid even saying at all
whether this is from July 1st. He was like,
I just talked to the president. He didn't
even want to answer about January six.
But Bret Baier pressed. I just don't think
Speaker 3: that's appropriate because I to
talk about what happens in Republican conferences.
I talk to the president numerous times. I continue
to talk to the president for six hours. Yes. I
mean, I talk to the president. I've talked to the
president. So I can't remember all the days I've
Speaker 1: talked to him, but I've certainly
talked to the president. Yeah, OK. So notice
that's two attempts. And he still doesn't
say on January 6th I spoke to him
Speaker 2: and on that day was,
can you share any of the inside of
what he was thinking about that day,
Speaker 3: that the people we need to come testify
are the people who can testify to the fundamental
questions. Why didn't the United States
Capitol, the People's House, have an appropriate
security posture on that day? And what have we
done? Those are the people we need to hear from.
That's information and testimony we need to get.
That's what we should focus on. But I don't think
that Bennie Thompson, the chairman of this
committee, said everything's on the table,
Speaker 1: so he's off on Bennie
Thompson. So that started to get weird.
And then taking a cue from this, when Jim Jordan
appeared on Spectrum News, good for him. The
reporter tried to press him on the same stuff
and it was the same type of evasive nonsense.
Speaker 4: There's some confusion over what you
told Bret there on Fox News on Tuesday night. So
I want to clear it up. First of all, speak yes or
no. Did you speak with President Trump on January
6th? Yeah. I mean, I speak I spoke with the
president last week. I speak with the president
all the time. I spoke with him on January six.
Speaker 1: So here now we have an admission,
OK, in the time between the bear interview
and this one, now Jim Jordan admits, yes,
he probably realizes I'm not going
to be able to avoid answering this.
I will concede that we spoke on that day.
Speaker 4: I talked with President Trump
all the time. And that's that's I don't think
that's unusual. I would expect defense members of
Congress to talk with the president of the United
States when they're trying to get done the things
they told the voters in their district to do. I'm
actually kind of amazed sometimes that people keep
asking. But, of course, I talk to the president
talking. Like I said, I talked to him last week
on January six. Did you speak with him before,
during or after the Capitol was attacked?
Oh, I have to go, I, I, I spoke with him that day
after I think after I don't know if I spoke with
him in the morning or not and I just don't know.
Speaker 1: So this is when we started. You know,
there's a couple of possibilities at this point,
right? It's like, well, maybe he's he's alluding
to I spoke to him more than once. It was after and
before. But the idea that if it was only one phone
call, this was like this was a blockbuster event.
Riots incited by Trump, carried out by Trump ists,
you would remember was was the phone call before
any of that, meaning we didn't talk about the
riots because the riots hadn't happened.
If the phone call was during or after,
clearly the phone call would mostly be about
the riots. It's just not plausible. But this is
when we started to think maybe there were two
phone calls or even more I'd have to go back.
Speaker 4: And I mean, I don't
I don't I don't know that
when when those conversations happen. But but what
I know as I spoke about the time. But but Taylor,
the key here is the people we need to speak to.
Speaker 1: OK, so then he gets back to you're
not even talking we're not even talking to the
right people. You shouldn't be talking to me.
It shouldn't be about me and Trump. So the word
conversations, they're raised. Well, maybe there
were multiple calls. And then now Jim Jordan is
admitting that that there was more than one call.
So not exactly a guy who transmits honesty. And
if you're wondering why would he want to hide the
fact, the facts of when he spoke to Trump? Because
if he spoke to Trump during or after the riots,
he would have relevant knowledge about Trump state
of mind. The reports are Trump was gleeful about
the riots. Publicly, Trump had to pretend that
the riots were bad, at least to some degree,
even though he still said, I understand you
know your great people and I understand why
you're upset because the election was stolen.
That's why Jim Jordan would not want to concede
that he spoke to Trump while the riots
were going on or shortly thereafter. So
really something else, clearly a dishonest guy.
And we'll see what ultimately comes of this